COMMUNITIES ON A DAILY BASIS.
NEIL: JONATHAN SERRIE, THANK
YOU.
YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS CLAIM THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SENDING MIXED
SIGNALS ON HOW IT VIEWS THOSE
WHO SEEK ASYLUM IN THE COUNTRY
AT THE BORDER VERSUS THOUGH WHO
MIGHT BE SEEKING ASYLUM FROM
CUBA OR HAITI.
DEADSET AGAINST TELLING THEM
NOT IN EITHER COUNTRY TO TRY TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY OR GET
INTO BOATS AND GET TO THE
UNITED STATES.
DIFFERENT POLICIES THAT HAS
SENATORS, FINANCE COMMITTEE,
ENERGY COMMITTEE, THANK YOU.
IT’S THAT WE’RE POTENTIALLY
SENDING MIXED SIGNALS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE WHITE
HOUSE IS SAYING HERE?
>> WELL, FROM WHAT WE’RE
HEARING FROM THE PRESIDENT, IT
LOOKS LIKE PRESIDENT BIDEN
WANTS OPEN BORDER POLICIES FOR
EVERYBODY EXCEPT THE CUBAN
PEOPLE.
AND PERHAPS THAT MAKES SENSE,
NEIL, BECAUSE PRESIDENT BIDEN
WOULDN’T WANT PEOPLE TO COME
INTO OUR COUNTRY WHO MIGHT GIVE
TESTIMONY TO THE FAILURES OF
SOCIALISM AND CONTRADICT
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S FAR LEFT
AGENDA.
THOSE IMAGES FROM THE SOUTHERN
BORDER ARE JUST SHOCKING AND
NEIL, JUST YESTERDAY I WAS IN
BILLINGS, MONTANA HAVING A
BRIEFING WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE, CHIEF OF
POLICE
POLICE, THE COUNTY SHERIFF,
IT’S NOT TALKED ENOUGH ABOUT ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS THE FACT
THAT ILLEGAL DRUGS ARE COMING
ACROSS, THE HEROIN,
METHAMPHETAMINES, WE’LL SEE
RECORD NUMBER OF HOMICIDES IN
BILLINGS, MONTANA.
WE’RE A NORTHERN BORDER STATE
WITH A SOUTHERN BORDER CRISIS,
80% OF OUR FELONIES AND VIOLENT
CRIMES ARE TIED TO DRUGS, THOSE
DRUGS COMING IN FROM MEXICO.
SO, HE IS SENDING A
CONTRADICTING MESSAGE, THE
PRESIDENT.
WIDE OPEN BORDER ON THE SOUTH
AND TELLING THE CUBAN PEOPLE
YOU’RE NOT ALLOWED TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, THE ARGUMENT
WAS THAT HE WAS LOOKING AT
THEIR SAFETY AS WELL AS THE
SAFETY OF AMERICAN EXILES, OR
CUBAN EXILES IN FLORIDA TRYING
TO MAKE THE TRIP SOUTH TO
PROVIDE SUPPLIES, FOOD, EVEN A
MEANS FOR CUBANS TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES, THAT IT’S
DANGEROUS, SO DON’T DO IT.
BUT HE DID CRITICIZE COMMUNISM
AS A FAILED PHILOSOPHY AND CUBA
AS A FAILED STATE, BUT YOU WANT
HIM TO ACT ON THAT, RIGHT?
WHAT SPECIFICALLY REGARDING
CUBA WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE HIM
DO?
>> WELL, THIS NOTION OF THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THE TREK
ACROSS THE WATER FOR CUBES BANS
IS DANGEROUS AND I WOULD AGREE,
THAT’S TRUE.
BUT THE TREK ACROSS THE MEXICAN
DESERT FROM THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE REFUGEES ARE COMING
OUT OF CENTRAL AMERICA, IT’S
EQUALLY DANGEROUS, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE HIGH TEMPERATURES AND
AS YOU KNOW, NEIL.
NEIL: RIGHT.
>> MANY OF THOSE FOLKS ARE
FAMILIES WITH SMALL CHILDREN SO
THAT’S AN ARGUMENT.
THERE IS A PROCESS TO BE
FOLLOWED BY SEEKING ASYLUM AND
WHETHER YOU ARE A CUBAN OR
WHETHER YOU’RE FROM A NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRY, THE PROCESS,
THE PROBLEM WE HAVE ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IS PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS REVOKED THE POLICY
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IN
PLACE THAT SAID IF YOU CLAIM
ASYLUM, YOU HAVE TO REMAIN IN
MEXICO UNTIL IT’S ADJUDICATED
AND THAT’S COMMON SENSE.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN SUSPENDED
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S POLICIES AND
WE ARE GOING TO SEE PERHAPS A
RECORD LEVEL OF ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
THE MONTH OF JUNE, IT WAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER IN 21 IS YEARS.
>> YOU KNOW, WHILE I HAVE YOU,
ON THAT SUBJECT, SENATOR, THE
PRESIDENT HAS PROMISED THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL APPEAL
WHAT HE CALLS A DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTING RULING BY FEDERAL
JUDGE IN TEXAS ON THIS PROGRAM
THAT PROTECTS CERTAIN
IMMIGRANTS BROUGHT INTO THE
U.S. AND THAT HE’LL ADDRESS
WHAT THIS JUDGE FORGOT.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS AND WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO THE CHILDREN OF
ILLEGALS WHO GREW UP IN THIS
COUNTRY AND NOW SEE IT AS THEIR
COUNTRY?
>> YEAH, WELL, THERE’S A PATH
FORWARD HERE, NEIL, WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
WORKING TOGETHER TO DEFINE A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP THAT
FOLLOWS ESTABLISHED PATHS AND
PROCESSES THAT MANY, MANY
AMERICANS NOW WENT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WHO ONCE WERE NOT
CITIZENS AND NOW ARE CITIZENS,
BUT WE’RE NOT GOING TO GO DOWN
A PASS OF GRANT BEING AMNESTY,
THERE’S A PATH, A PROCESS THAT
MILLIONS HAVE GONE THROUGH WHO
ARE NOW AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO
SHOULD FOLLOW WHAT THEY
PROCESS.
THAT’S A SOLVABLE PROBLEM AND I
THINK WE COULD FIND A
BIPARTISAN SOLUTION HOPEFULLY
WITH LONG ESTABLISHED PROCESS.
>> SENATOR, WHILE I HAVE YOU,
OBVIOUSLY, CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS
TO BEGIN AT LEAST DEBATE VOTING
ON THIS THREE AND A HALF
TRILLION DOLLAR SO-CALLED HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
APART FROM THAT IS THE ROUGHLY
$1 TRILLION REAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ONLY.
ARE YOU A YES VOTE ON THAT, ON
THE ROUGHLY $1 TRILLION PLAN
THAT DOES SEEM TO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, NOT
NECESSARILY THE 31/2 TRILLION
DOLLAR ONE THAT CLEARLY DOES
NOT?
>> YEAH, WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
WE’VE GOT TO SEE HOW TO PAY FOR
IT.
HOW DO YOU PAY FOR IT?
WE’RE $30 TRILLION IN DEBT AND
WAITING TO GET CLARITY ON WHAT
THE ADDITIONAL SPENDING, AND
ALSO WANT TO SEE WHAT THE CBO
SAYS ABOUT IT, THAT’S GOING TO
COME OUT SOON.
BUT NEIL, I HAVE TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON THAT $31/2 TRILLION
OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS WOULD BE THE LARGEST
SPENDING BILL PASSED IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY, THIS IS
A MASSIVE SPENDING BILL, IT’S A
MASSIVE TAX INCREASE, IT IS A
LURCH TO THE LEFT LIKE WE’VE
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
IT OUGHT TO BE CONCERNING BY
EVERY AMERICAN AND TAKES JUST
ONE DEMOCRAT SENATOR, ONE,
EVERY REPUBLICAN IS GOING TO BE
OPPOSED TO IT, ONE DEMOCRAT
SENATOR TO HOPEFULLY BRING
COMMON SENSE TO STOP THIS,
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE HOPING FOR,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE COMPLETELY
LEFT OFF IN NEGOTIATIONS ON
THIS 31/2 TRILLION DOLLAR
MASSIVE DEMOCRAT SPENDING
PACKAGE.
NEIL: THE FACT THAT HE WANTS TO
STICK TAXES ON WELL-TO-DO, OR
THE INFLATION THAT COULD COME
AS A RESULT OF, ON THE TAX OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> INFLATION IS A TAX INCREASE
FOR EVERYBODY.
IT JUST STARTS TO SHRINK THE
PAYCHECK, BUT THE TAX
PHYSICALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE,
SURELY IS THEY’RE LOOKING TO
RAISE CAPITAL GAIN TAXES TO
HIGHER THAN ANY LEVEL, AND
DOUBLING THE CAN’T GAINS,
MASSIVE INCREASE IN THE DEATH
TAX AS WELL AS RAISING THE
TAXES ON BUSINESSES, THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE, WHICH
AGAIN, IF ANYBODY IS CHEERING
RIGHT NOW, NEIL, IT’S THE
CHINESE.
IF WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE
COMPETITIVE TO CHINA WE NEED TO
STICK TO PRESIDENT TRUMP’S AND
THE REPUBLICAN TAX PACKAGE WE
PASSED BACK IN 2017.
THAT INCENTIVIZES GROWTH, IT
INCENTIVIZES KEEPING JOBS IN
AMERICA.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT.
THE BATTLE IS ON, SENATOR
DAINES, THANK YOU.
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND,